welcome to the opening ceremony for the
2019 u.s. Senior Championships US Junior
Championship and us girls junior
championship big round of applause for
all of the competitors that qualified to
be here today Nick a speaker any speaker
three number three really great to be
hosting the Junior Championship for the
junior girls and especially the seniors
Invitational I'm happy to see all of you
folks again seems like everybody's
coming home and look like yesterday when
I was playing Rachel League at the age
of five and now that she's the youngest
girl to ever play in the juniors at the
age of nine and Rachel draws bearing
number two this is the first year that
u.s. chess has been able to provide a
scholarship ten thousand dollars for the
winner of the u.s. junior in the u.s.
girls championships when we were able to
do that with support from Dwayne and Sue
barber through the barber foundation and
from u.s. chess itself so good luck to
everybody who's playing in those events
and good luck to everybody
[Applause]